[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through velocity to find practical
advice that you can use your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler this time we have
a special guest carnades
so carnadius is obviously a pseudonym
nobody's really named that but it is a
real life person on here and he is the
author of a recent book our all lives
equal why cost benefit analysis values
Rich lives more and how philosophy can
fix it which is a bit of a mouthful and
you're going to get to know them pretty
well in this this episode he also has an
educational YouTube channel that is
focused on philosophy and he's been
doing that for close to 10 years he's
got over 13 million views he is
approaching 125
000 subscribers it might pass that up
tonight or in the near future and he's
got almost a thousand videos and he's
also got a really well put together
educational website
carneadies.org we'll put a link to that
in the show notes for anybody who'd like
to go check that out we both highly
recommend that so Carnegie's anything
else that you want to say by way of
introduction there's a lot of other
things that even with your pseudonym I
think we could have said what else would
you like to say about yourself
um sure well first I'd like to say thank
you so much for uh having me on the show
and chatting with me today
um about the book I'm sure we'll get
into some of this but uh yeah excited to
be talking about um philosophy exciting
to be talking with people who who work
in doing public philosophy and engaging
folks
um I do in in my day-to-day life do work
in International Development that we'll
chat about a little bit I've worked for
the World Bank I've worked for the Gates
Foundation I've worked for a couple of
U.S government
um International assistant agencies so
that's kind of my my day job and then my
my life outside of that is is doing
educational philosophy so uh so a little
bit of the the Dual side of that um that
I think maybe we'll get a chance to talk
about here today yeah so go ahead I got
a question
um uh is it all you now or do you have a
team with your YouTube channel that is a
that is a great question when I started
the YouTube channel I was like maybe one
day I'll have a team so I want to frame
this in terms of we and so often I'll
say we at cardieties.org do these things
it is a hundred percent just me that
produces these things and it's only it's
only me I I do say that we still kind of
to give myself this feeling of like
there's more people working on this it's
really just me that's putting these
together ah the aspirational exactly I
asked you that exactly because I heard
you're referring to yourself I believe
both in the book as well as a couple of
the videos I saw you that's we oh yeah
you know yeah no it's an aspirational
week for sure I I hate to like begin
with a digression but I'm going to uh
which is that I'm I'm kind of curious uh
on your end Carnitas um so I get pitches
because I have a YouTube channel and you
know we we're almost like at the same
exact level interestingly enough I get
pictures like every single week from
somebody who thinks that they're going
to make my life easier but
they would complicate my work
significantly were I to bring them on
board you know like they want to help me
out with thumbnails they don't want to
help me with the SEO or stuff like that
and I'm I don't have a team either and I
I kind of feel like I don't want to have
a team because it would take too long to
train anybody in doing the kind of work
that I do is is that the same for you oh
a hundred percent completely I feel that
there there might be some point and
there's definitely a point where some
YouTubers get to where it's clear that
the amount of whether it's editing work
or something else that they do yeah
ringing someone on it would be useful
but I I also get offers for people who
say oh I want to do these various things
for your videos help you with it and
help you with that and I'm like the
amount of work it would take for me to
do that is so much more than me just
doing some of these processes myself so
yeah no I'm definitely in the same boat
on that have you ever had anyone who
tried to pitch being an intern for you
because I've had that a few times I
haven't had that one
the same sort of logic though I thought
it would take so much work to like bring
them up to speed you know I don't know
if this would be valuable for me yeah
yeah completely agree
but is that's why you have universities
for TAS well do you think there's so
here's another digression point but do
you think there's something about like
doing public philosophy that makes it
less easy to bring somebody in and just
help out than it would be with like cat
videos or I don't know little quotes or
stuff like that I think I think it's a
good question I think and this is a
little bit gets to kind of My Philosophy
for but lack of a better word of making
videos which is around I try to Center
the ideas and the arguments and do as
little as possible as I can on kind of
the fancy editing or making everything
look nice if you've seen my videos there
very basic they're very simple and that
is by Design to a certain degree in part
because I want to Center the ideas and
in part because I don't want to spend
all of my time doing video editing oh
yeah and so I wonder if Philosophy by
Nature being something that tries to
Center those ideas and Concepts lends
itself to people who say we want want to
talk about the ideas the having
something with the best graphics or the
best transitions isn't isn't going to
give us that much value add but I don't
know I mean there are some big
philosophy channels out there that I
call it Glitz you know they spend a lot
of time on the glitz and maybe less time
on really good content and they have
lots of I mean they make us look like
little tiny oh we're two-bit exactly
compared to that compared to you know
and I I won't like you know name names
or anything people can find them easily
enough
um I mean so let me ask you this uh we
were like so far off script at this
point but as somebody who does public
philosophy somebody I mean you have a
massive range as well so you know you
know your stuff you know a lot of other
people's stuff when you look at those
channels
um do you you know do you find them
interesting or useful these these big
high production kind a low content
channels where it's much more about like
dramatization or you know making up
scenarios or you know that that sort of
thing do you find that interesting at
all or do you see that as like ah it's
not really philosophy anymore I I see
those things in the same way I feel as I
read plays by Sartre or something I see
them as someone who understands the
philosophy ideas well enough to produce
something that is engaging for a broad
audience that maybe connects with those
ideas and touches on them and riffs on
them and so I I see them fit into more
almost an artistic space than directly a
philosophy space and when I see them as
that they they're engaging and
interesting for me because I I look at
them almost with an aesthetic lens of
how are you telling this story or doing
these things and then they become
interesting but if I look at them with
kind of that strict just is this clearly
dictating philosophy I I say yeah I
don't know how much there is there but
when I when I look at them kind of in
the frame of this is someone that has a
background in philosophy that's giving
me an artistic piece that maybe has bits
of philosophy in it then then I find
that I'm more engaged with it so so that
because it all depends upon the Talos or
the ends which they're actually trying
to go for and how well they've actually
executed on those
yeah yeah yeah
and they so they could be a good Gateway
into you better philosophy in other
words yeah
oh don't go get too much in your little
Ivory Tower
yeah we're gonna start we're gonna start
gatekeeping from the river West radio
well let's let's come back to some of
the things that we were originally going
to ask you about before we get to the
book which we'll have plenty of time so
why uses pseudonym and keep your face
off of your own videos you know clearly
you're not in it for the fame right or a
celebrity yeah good good question
um so the work that I do in my uh day
job takes me to a lot of places around
the world
um and it puts me in uh situations where
I am in countries that are often uh
hostile to people that are non-religious
um being being a philosophical skeptic
is a part of my channel and and not
being religious is a part of that
um and so critiquing uh all any number
of sources of knowledge including
religion is a part of my channel
um and there are a lot of countries that
I work in and have worked in where
that's illegal and that can be punished
and so I try to as much as I can keep my
personality online and my personality
out in the real world separate to a
certain degree uh both for personal
safety but also to kind of help help
preserve the work that I'm doing in my
day job and not have it have too much
crossover or or get judged by people
that say oh we're aware of you online in
some way
so it's essentially a secret identity
to a certain degree I I I try not to
guard it to to uh jealously for for
people that uh I I actually know in
person um but I just yeah I'm a little
cautious of having it out there
somewhere where someone can search it
and be like oh this person said all of
these things and
do you have to tell the people that you
know in person who know that you are
cardiologist that
um they shouldn't Reveal Your your
identity I yeah I usually I usually try
to tell people that yeah keep it keep it
separate keep it keep it distinct and
usually I mean so much of what
everything that we do is online right
now I say if you're if you're talking to
someone in person like have it in person
it's fine but it's amazing what people
can find out about you on the internet
like I was like oh I don't have a wiki
Wikipedia page I'm fine but there's like
wikitubia that has Wikipedia pages for
all everyone that has a certain size
YouTube channel out there and they've
they've listed a surprising number of
pieces of information about me on that's
interesting it it was surprising and
shocking to me I was like uh let me just
be as careful as I can with this so a
bit of a secret identity but not not too
much
yeah so to try to maybe not probe
yourself so much as uh your uh Alter Ego
here is um so you said that uh
skepticism is a big part of your channel
um so and I we know that uh carnades or
carniades depending on how you want to
uh read the Greek there
um is the name of a an ancient skeptic
why did you choose him great question
um so I I was aware that I wanted uh
kind of an ancient Greek skeptic um to
play with it I was playing with a couple
of them I was reading uh some of these
old stories and and anecdotes about
these different Skeptics and there was
this one story about uh carnades that
really struck me
um which is there's a story of he and a
number of other scholarchs so so
Carnegie's was um a scholar of Plato's
Academy of the the
um skeptical Academy and he and a number
of other Scholars went to Rome to
present as an embassy to present an
Athenian petition to the Roman senate
and The Story Goes that he uh presented
the Roman senate and spoke to the
Senators and the people
um and the first day he came he spoke
all of these uh platonic Arguments for
justice and in favor of Plato's
traditional conceptions of justice and
they were wowed and impressed by his
oratory skills but then the next day he
came and he completely debunked all of
the arguments that he had just presented
and went in the other direction and
showed all the flaws and the things he
had presented and said all these things
against his own arguments and the Roman
senators were so shocked by this and
were so concerned that these Greek
philosophers were coming on and
spreading these dangerous ideas of of
free thinking and being able to question
ideas that they immediately granted the
Athenian petition and sent the
philosophers home least they uh corrupt
the minds of the Roman Youth and so that
that story struck me because I liked
that idea of being able to argue both
sides of an idea and being able to
present things from different angles and
I would say my own skepticism doesn't
certainly perfectly align with uh
carnides he's more of an academic
skeptic I'm more of a peronian skeptic
um but that story and that idea of kind
of presenting both sides and pushing
from both sides was something that was
uh really impactful for me and I I
wanted to kind of bring that
um to bear and and I was aware
Carnegie's was a little-known figure and
so I was able to kind of take on a
moniker that people wouldn't have other
associations with strongly like Cicero
right or yeah Aristotle so there's
there's all sorts of Aristotle accounts
out there on Twitter that are just awful
Aristotle wouldn't have said this this
nonsense that you're saying I was
actually I was interested in asking you
about the both sides uh thing but I I I
I think for our listeners it might be
useful to ask you so what's the
difference between pyroni and skepticism
and academic skepticism because those
aren't terms that they've probably heard
although they could go to your channel
and easily find videos talking about
that right yeah so I I I can speak to it
a little bit um I mean there are two
Traditions that I think I think it's I
want to say sexist empiricus that
outlines kind of these two Traditions um
within skepticism and it kind of defines
himself against the academic Skeptics um
but it's the idea if you think if we
categorize everyone that's not a skeptic
as someone that thinks that I have
knowledge or or I know something then
you have academic Skeptics that thinks
knowledge is impossible they are sent to
the claim and accept the claim that
knowledge is impossible you cannot have
any knowledge of all and then peronian
Skeptics suspend a judgment on that
claim so you have people that say yes
knowledge is possible no knowledge is
impossible and people that say I don't
know if knowledge is possible
it's kind of a if you want a very basic
kind of slimmed down dichotomy of of the
positions it's that and so the peroneian
Skeptics fit more in the world of
lacking belief and trying to seek kind
of ataraxia or a lack of beliefs
um and and this state of suspension
complete suspension of judgment whereas
the academic Skeptics are more in the
realm of arguing for the specific claim
that knowledge is impossible
okay yeah this is how I would explain it
at least I think that's quite helpful
yeah yeah so the both sides thing why do
you see that as I mean you could be
accused of both sidesism right and this
is something completely different than
than that technique
um what is it about presenting both
sides or multiple sides that you find
compelling or
that's a great question I'd say that
it's compelling to me because I think it
is getting too into a specific position
or too into a certain Dogma you can end
up with blinders on you can end up blind
to weaknesses to your own argument and
you can be put into a world where you
accept you you get uh kind of um
cognitive biases where you say oh I'm
just going to accept the piece of
evidence that confirmed my argument and
I'm going to ignore the ones that don't
and I think there's a it's a dangerous
mental space to get in when you have
kind of accepted something and you don't
look at the other side of a given
argument you can become dogmatically
committed to something
um and when you try to at least in terms
of your beliefs look at both sides of
something and say what are the reasons
that I could doubt this thing what are
the reasons that go against this how can
I balance this argument out I think it
can lead to a a headspace that lets you
be a little bit free of some of those
dogmas and not kind of be so attached to
something that if if new information
came you wouldn't you wouldn't be able
to question it
um so I I think that's a piece of it I
think it's also honestly uh there's
not as much from the both side side but
just the general skepticism side I think
there there's a calming sense for me of
the possibility that I might be wrong I
think some people get get very nervous
about that for me when when something is
going bad in the world like the the
possibility that I could be dreaming or
the possibility that I could be in The
Matrix that makes me happy that that
makes me call when something goes
horribly wrong I say you know what I
might wake up tomorrow and this all
might be different and that I I find a
lot of Peace in that so I I think
there's a couple of those things that
that go into the skepticism for me
that's that's very very interesting
because I think that's probably a
minority thing but it does make a lot of
sense what were you gonna say Dan
it's fairly wholeheartedly
what Carnegie's just said there that I
tried to hold myself to
that my ideas are not me and that these
two things must be separated because if
they become me and when someone attacks
my ideas I will see them as attacking me
yeah that emotional investment right
right yeah
to try to be as low Dogma as possible I
don't know if there's any way to be
totally for your Dogma as a human being
on but
um specifically do you have any
practices philosophical practices that
you use to do to try to um
elicit this state within yourself so
we've talked about a number of different
practices here within our own show and
if you got one to share I'd be lovely
love to hear it yeah I I mean I I can
definitely to
speak to it to a certain degree I mean I
I love going through if I'm in a
situation where I have that kind of
moment of being feeling over invested in
something being able to take that step
back and almost away from myself and say
what if I were what what if I were a
minor part character in someone else's
story what if I were uh just dreaming
now what if I were in this different
situation where my experience isn't
centered in this in someone else's
experience is what's centered and I
don't know I've I've had not not to get
too weird and mystical but but through
through my life I feel like I'm
sometimes able to have these not out of
body experiences but experiences where I
can step back from myself and say I'm
just someone that's living this
experience or or seeing these things
through this very narrow lens very
narrow ideology I could be wrong I could
be in this situation so taking that
pause taking that step back and even
just thinking of like if if this were a
dream would everything be and and I woke
up in a moment would everything be as
intense and as horrible as or bad as I
think it is right now and I think that
idea of even just going through
skeptical scenarios and these ideas of
what if I was being deceived can can
bring me and does bring me a lot of
Peace so I don't know if that's a
perfect practice that anyone else can
use but um I I think thinking through
some of those possible skeptical
scenarios sometimes can bring me peace
of oh maybe this isn't as bad as I think
it is well I mean it brings up something
and this is a technical term you know
from Greek philosophy that you're very
familiar with the at the app okay right
that's originally associated with
skepticism and then makes its way into
phenomenology through Edmund hussarel
and other people taking that terminology
and bringing it in and using it to mean
something a bit different
um
but what you're doing there does sound
like something in between the the
original skeptical you know suspending
judgment
um point of which is to you know make
you live a better life uh not just to
like be a devil's advocate all the time
or something like that but also the
phenomenological one where you do like
you said you think about how things
could be different and you're not just
thinking about like it and you could say
a purely objective way oh the outside
world you know what like Crystal did all
these really really boring variations of
well what if the red ball was green you
know or had a Green Dot and stuff like
that but you could think about like okay
so what if I
um you know what if I was older what if
I was younger what if I was a different
gender you know how would I be seeing
things and what you're varying is is uh
more your your personality and your
background and your
what would you call it your your
identity right and saying what's what's
the world like then
for our viewers uh could you define that
term oh app okay
I'll let I'll let uh carnate is to do it
because I don't I don't know if I I do a
good job please go ahead if if you have
a good definition for us well I mean so
it literally means
um
to to like hold back you know hold hold
from something
um and it was you know it was this term
that the Skeptics used for withholding
judgment for
not immediately buying into things and I
mean you do see this in in other
philosophies like the stoics when they
talk about
um not immediately accepting Fantasia
appearances or imaginations as what they
are but the Skeptics obviously took it
much further right it's it's like
absolutely Central to what they're doing
so
what do you what do you think Dan does
that work
pretty well okay yeah yeah I think it's
good enough for what we need to go
through
um I guess the only other thought I
could think of is um
I don't know this was from a
an author I was reading about a author
and how she was motivating herself to
write her books was that she would
create a
um another personality and she named it
um for her for him for herself that was
the one that was like kicking her butt
to do the thing I'm thinking like Could
you
um could you hold like okay I'm gonna
like have Bob here who's my I'm gonna
argue as Bob here for this argument over
here and I'm gonna argue with James does
this argument over here and I'm gonna be
like the Arbiter uh and think of myself
as the the one that's in the middle and
looking at these two different person
people putting up their bills still mans
of their particular arguments that's
actually a really interesting way to
frame it so is is that how a skeptic
could like set things up for themselves
as yeah not just a writer but like going
through day to day like you've got I I
you know I don't want to say the angel
the devil under your shoulder it's more
like you know uh a sort of you on one
side and a sort of you on the other side
that brings out different aspects of a
situation yeah and and I think that uh
some people can do this in some some
Skeptics do this with with really
thinking of of real people who they're
they're aware of that that do disagree
on these things I think we we often all
know that and those people who may
disagree with us or who are our best
opponents or or people who would always
argue with us and so imagining those
people even of saying that I know I I
don't know within within politics you
you have one political thing you you
know that relative that's on the other
side of the political Spectrum not
saying of coming up with that person
that perhaps in in the best light what
would they argue what would they say
what's the conversation that they would
have back to me in with that strongest
Steel Man and so I think you can even
embody those those ideas further and say
who's that person that I know that would
would present a really good argument
against me who who would always be able
to catch where I'm doing something wrong
and would expose those holes so that I
can whether that's make my argument
better or arrive at a state of of lack
of belief what have you um I I think
there's there's definitely benefits to
that
in learning foreign languages like
Spanish
um I create a Persona that's it's me but
the Spanish-speaking version of me
um and it definitely helps especially
getting into like the voice of it um but
I also find that I can usually recall
arguments of other people if I'm either
thinking their voice or I might be even
impersonating them and I wonder if
there's like if you can kind of even
step into their shoes it allows you to
hone that that idea that they're holding
um in a little bit better way I know I
know actors talk about that a lot of
being able to you get into the
physicality of an individual you get
into the voice of someone you get you're
better able to understand their
objectives and their ideas and and put
yourself in a different frame of
reference than you would if you're if
you're just embodying yourself
that's very interesting I mean maybe
down the line we should have you on as a
guest and just talk through skepticism
yeah
um because we do have to move on
I wanted to before we get into the book
which we will get into
um doing philosophy on YouTube so you've
been doing it now for about 10 years
um what made you want to start doing
that in the first place what got you I
mean it's public philosophy that you're
doing right it's not just purely
academic Dan invoked the term Ivory
Tower earlier which a lot of people are
doing and doing quite poorly on YouTube
so I would I would say I I remember when
I started the Channel that I had seen
things out there that looked like I
don't know Khan Academy or these other
educational YouTube channels that were
focused on other Concepts whether that's
math whether that's English for that
something else to help people learn
um and I also remember as a kid before I
ever set foot in a philosophy classroom
I thought a lot about philosophy but
didn't have a name for it I thought a
lot about these ideas and I remember
stepping into a philosophy classroom for
the first time and being like these are
the people who are talking about the
things that I've thought about my entire
life and so I wanted to doing public
philosophy give people who never get the
chance to go into a philosophy classroom
but have some of those questions who are
thinking about uh whether that's
epistemology or metaphysics but don't
have the names for those things give
them the opportunity to say I I have
this kind of idea of something I'm
curious about but I'm not going to be
able to get a degree Korean philosophy
or or take a philosophy class and be
able to still engage with those Concepts
because I think from my perspective
philosophy is something that we all
should have access to and we should be
able people should be able to learn
about ethics and Justice that are so
important to people's lives but not
everyone gets the chance to study
academic philosophy or philosophy in a
professional setting and so I wanted to
have a place where people who think hard
about these things but maybe never have
the chance to do formal philosophy could
engage and could learn a little bit or
get their feet wet a bit with some of
the videos that I have so that they
could they could maybe take the next
step on their own
that makes a lot of sense yeah
now another question that I had for you
so 10 years in almost
um
there's a lot of people who do not just
philosophy but you know other things in
Humanities on YouTube and they they kind
of Peter out after a year or two
it's like they run out of ideas or they
run out of uh energy and you're doing
this on the side you're doing this kind
of Moonlighting rather than as your your
full-time gig so what has kept you
persevering in it to the point where
you've now got almost a thousand videos
that's a great question so I remember
when I first started the channel I
wanted this to be something that I never
looked at as a chore I wanted it to be
something I was always excited to do
um and it's not to say it has never felt
that way or a little bit but I wanted to
have my videos be low enough budget and
basic enough that I felt I could always
be excited to do another one and two
that I wouldn't spend all of my time
doing video editing and fancy graphics
and all of this stuff because I I see
these channels as well and I hear from
people that that start a philosophy
Channel and have made two videos and
then stop and they're these highly
produced fan fancy beautiful videos on a
couple of Concepts and then they just
disappear and drop off the face of the
Earth and so I I didn't want to be in
that in that place and so I wanted to do
something that would always be easy for
me to do but also would always Center
kind of the the ideas and the concepts
and so I could spend my time doing the
thing that I love which is learning
about philosophy engaging with
philosophers and engaging with those
ideas and not sitting around video
editing or staring at a video editing
software or sound editing software not
to say I don't do that sometimes but um
yeah get having that and so I think I've
been able to keep up the the pace of
videos and the videos I've done because
I've kept it fairly basic when it comes
to the the Frills and the the extra
stuff
yeah I mean it's it's interesting
because when I was you know doing the
research for this this session I and
looking at your channel we're almost
your channel and my channel are almost
like parallel to each other in terms of
uh you know time in growth
um
uh number of subscribers number of views
and we're doing we're doing pretty
similar stuff like you're just saying
not spending a ton of time on video
editing and really concentrating on
making good content you know stuff that
people could use you know people use my
my videos in classes I've used some of
your videos in my classes as resources
for my students and it strikes me that
like in some YouTube
um let's call them niches or segments
whatever whatever the word is that would
put us like in direct competition with
each other right you and I would be
Rivals but in a way like we're we're
what we're doing is complementary I
think somebody could watch one of your
videos and then watch one of my videos
and they would you know they could both
be on the same text the same thinker the
same topic and concept and it's it's not
like you know you would have your rival
view over here and I would have my rival
take over here here we could actually be
saying almost the same thing and yet
somebody could derive
some Surplus benefit from it maybe for
sure I mean I I'm sure you see this in
comments on your videos but I often see
people who say I I listened to five
other people explain this different ways
but for something about the way that you
explain this one thing is what finally
made it click and I agree complete I
think that with education these things
are additive right when I want to learn
something on YouTube I go and I click
through the first video and if I don't
learn something there I click to the
next video in the next video and even if
I do understand the concept getting
those different perspectives and what
people choose to focus on and the way
they choose to frame it I think it's
complementary and I think because our
goal is educating and teaching people
about philosophy and doing public
philosophy in that way it is really
complementary to have extra resources
and have more resources for people yeah
yeah so
you know I'd be curious to know if you
get a lot of comments of this sort that
I got very early on and that was part of
what made me realize that it was worth
doing the YouTube work people would say
my instructor uh is awful they won't
explain anything they won't answer
questions I was flunking the class
um now I'm able to pass because you know
you did this thing on Aristotle or
whatever do you get a lot of those yeah
those are those are the comments that
make my day I definitely I definitely
get some of those comments um and it's
great particularly there'll be like some
weird concept I'll have like done a
video on Bayesian epistemology that I'm
like no one's going to watch this video
and if it's like a really small segment
of people that I'm I'm pitching to and
someone will say like I took a class in
this and I was having no idea and then I
watched these videos and it just it it
helped me understand or fill in the gaps
of what what someone wasn't saying so
yeah it's positive in one way right
because we can read it I'm doing a good
job right but it's also negative in
another way because we'd be oh there's
an awful lot of either bad or poorly
informed or lazy instructors out there
in Academia which is not a good thing we
want those people out
true true
but thankfully both of you are here to
help pick a slack
well we should talk oh go ahead Dan oh
yeah well I was just gonna say like
let's talk about the books it's yeah
it's book time so we've got this book
yeah yes so the subtitles again for our
listeners uh well the the book is called
are all lives equal right and then the
subtitle is this longish why cost
benefit analysis values Rich lives more
and how philosophy can fix it and I I
kind of think that between the uh title
and the subtitle
it's it's really well chosen because it
it kind of explains what the whole book
is about right you don't often see that
that's the good thing about having a
subtitle that could could be a small
abstract on its own is that it hopefully
hopefully gets the gets the point across
and hits all of the all of the pieces
um related to it I think the book is
trying to span a couple of disciplines
and so it's trying to pick up on both
people that care about philosophy but
also people that care about economics
and people that are trying to get those
two groups of people to talk to each
other
um and so I tried to highlight the fact
that this isn't just a book about
cost-benefit analysis this isn't just a
book about philosophy it's a book about
how philosophy can help fix what's wrong
with some parts of economics and
cost-benefit Analysis I mean it strikes
me that there's a third and maybe even
fourth group that are being targeted as
if not readers at least
um people to be have an argument made
into and you want policy makers and
politicians to take this seriously or at
least for their age maybe to read it and
Whisper their ears right and I was
wondering too I mean you mentioned some
of these ngos
um they're which now I know that you
work for yeah so I mean they're they're
like a fourth ngos institutions
um you know whatever is not a government
itself you know run by politicians those
those are people who are making
um decisions that massively impact our
life if you like an electrical utility
right
um or yeah I'd say there's there's a lot
of potential audiences here both kind of
on the academic side of looking at the
concepts of philosophy and economics and
how they are in conversation but also
the practical application and that some
of the the impetus and the push for me
in in writing this and trying to get it
out there is is from the Practical side
it's from the side of I I work in in
policy every day and I see rooms full of
economists and empty of philosophers and
I want to have there be a voice for
philosophy and ethics in some of these
considerations in those rooms and so I
there there's some desire for this to be
putting philosophy or getting philosophy
in the door there's a a piece that I
have at the very end of the book in the
in the final thoughts of kind of let
philosophy in and it's this plea to say
a lot of these institutions have become
overgrown with only people from
economics as a discipline let some of
the other Humanities in whether that's
historians or philosophers or whoever
chew these conversations because I think
they can become all the Richer for it
and get away from some of kind of the
group think that I I think has plagued
some of these institutions to a certain
degree
I like the point where you're talking
about basically you know if you've got a
whole bunch of economists and you say
Okay optimize this function yeah they go
yes sir go right to do it without
actually thinking about why you're doing
it in the first place this is one of the
things that I I loved about
um when I first got introduced to
philosophy in a more serious way in
college like I was spending all this
time in computer science learning how to
do these things but not any of the
arguments for why I should be doing that
yeah yeah
I had a friend who was um originally an
economics major at at Penn State and he
kept asking so many foundational
questions you know the whys and stuff
like that that eventually they actually
told him you need to quit asking those
questions and go over to the philosophy
Department because that's the slum where
we send people to screw around with that
sort of thing and he did and he enjoyed
it very much you know but I think that's
kind of common that oh yeah
economists shy away from questions of
from any normative questions really if
you ask should we be doing this
economist say oh no no I don't touch
that go talk to the philosophers they
and they push that off and I worry that
disciplines have become so siled that
sure it's great for philosophy because
philosophy has the tools to talk about
ethics and philosophy as the tools to
have that conversation but yeah unless
we kind of bring those conversations
back into conversation with the people
that we're asking those initial
questions of wait a second why do we
make this assumption in economics still
um if if we don't bring that those
people who have the tools to ask those
ethical questions in I think you missed
something and you lose something yeah
and there and there's two sides to it
like I can think of a lot of my
colleagues if I'm like mentally walking
down the hallway I sit at Marquette
University where I teach occasionally
and imagine putting them in any sort of
practical situation it could be with
economists it could be doing business
ethics it could be doing you know bio
medical ethics in an actual hospital and
them just being terrible at it
and not not being able to communicate
effectively and then them getting ticked
off or something and going back off to
their office and like thinking to
themselves see those you know those
economists they're all bad people yeah
um and that's that's almost the opposite
of what you're arguing for right but you
know we can't just like throw any old
philosophers in there because a lot of
them would be almost counterproductive
right yeah and I think there's a the the
book does try to to walk this line in
between because I think that one of the
mistakes economists have made is
becoming of is shutting out alternative
views I think that philosophers often
have perhaps naive expectations about
the way that the world can actually work
and can effectively be used and they
come up with this beautiful theory that
they say oh it'll work perfectly just go
operationalize and figure out how to do
this anymore as willing to get down into
the nitty-gritty of what does that
actually mean and so I think the the
flaw coming from the economists is
excluding other disciplines and say and
and taking their assumptions as and the
assumptions of Economics as kind of a a
Dogma to a certain degree but the the
flaw of the philosophers is saying oh we
have this General very abstract Theory
I'm sure it'll work fine in practice it
it'll be fine I I have this beautiful
argument about it it'll work fine in
practice and I think bringing those two
into conversation so the philosophers
can realize uh there may be some you may
have to adapt your theory to fit the
world
um but also the economists can realize
that there may be some legitimate
concerns to your basic underlying
assumptions that these philosophers are
raising so I I hope to challenge uh in a
good skeptical tradition challenge both
sides assumptions a little bit um in the
discussion and it seems like there's
also one more extra layer of you can
operationalize it in a case study but
does that mean that you can actually uh
scale that up to a large group of people
no yeah that is that is a question I try
in the book so I I propose this uh
slightly different uh methodology to use
in cost-benefit analysis and one of the
critiques that I know I I will get from
economists and have gotten from
Economist that I've presented this to is
show us how this can be operationalized
and so I try to take I have a couple
chapters where I try to show like this
is really how you could in a
nitty-gritty sense operationalize this
for all of these considerations and all
of these concerns that may come into
play
um but I can only do so much in a book
without actually doing that kind of
field test case yeah I mean there's
there's a lot of
um you build them as thought experiments
and they're examples essentially like
little case studies imagine this is the
case right and then there are two
chapters that are extended case studies
one about
um you know
um broken windows policing and
um disparate impacts on communities
bearing the brunt of policing and then
the whole covid epidemic and vaccines
um so I think I think there's a lot of
case being made in the book for how this
could be applied
um
I think it might be useful because we've
mentioned cost-benefit analysis and I
don't know that all of our listeners are
necessarily going to know what it means
although I think once it's explained
it's pretty pretty intuitive right
sure could you run us through what cost
benefit analysis yeah sure so I I like
to explain it to uh philosophers as uh
what basically economists inherited the
legacy of of consequentialism in many
ways you'll see pictures of of Jon
Stewart Mill and Jeremy Bentham in
economics departments up as as founding
fathers and in some ways of economics
and so cost benefit analysis is this
attempt to operationalize a
consequentialist calculus basically
you're taking you're looking at a
government policy you're saying what's
all the good that this policy is going
to do what's all the harm this policy is
going to do we're going to subtract the
the bad from the good and we're going to
see how much good net good did we cause
in the world
and there's a lot more details
economists turn all of that into money
of course because they're economists and
so they shift over into dollars and
cents instead of kind of good and bad or
or pain and pleasure or what have you
and there's some issues that I raise in
the book with how that uh conversion and
how that measurement happens
um but but the basic idea I think is a
really intuitive one and it's one of the
reasons that economists kind of take it
as of course this would be a good idea
to do of let's take these uh what what
is all the good and what's all the bad
policies going to do add it together and
say is this a good policy to do or is a
different policy a better policy to do
right so it allows us to to weigh
policies against each other and compare
them in ways that are um you could say
publicly accessible right
um You might not agree with the
calculations and all the bases of them
but at least there's numbers that you
can point to right and you have a
methodology that's successful people
understand why a decision is being made
it's not a decision that's being done in
a back cloak room it's clear that we we
have three policies we assessed it open
with public methodology that everyone
knows everyone's aware of and this
policy one and it's clear why we might
choose a particular policy because
everything's open everything's
accessible it's not that we propose
these three policies a committee went
into a back room and they came out with
this is the policy we're going with and
you you have the potential for bias and
the potential for suspicion there yeah
one of the things I really like about
the book is that you're not as a lot of
ethicists would be doing or policy you
know uh Advocates so saying ah cost
benefit analysis uh not perfect so no
good you know as a matter of fact you
point out at one point I think towards
the end of the book you say philosophers
need to stop letting the best be the
enemy of the the good right perfect yeah
the perfect right right don't let the
perfect bdn be the good exactly and I I
I definitely think that I think that
philosophers often take this let's come
up with this perfect beautiful
crystalline system that may not work in
the real world at all
um but if there's a single flaw with
this thing that we're doing oh we're
gonna we're gonna throw it out the
window and don't realize
um what uh
economists might call the um the the
trade-offs or the what's the word that
I'm looking for it'll come to me um but
the the the the
um opportunity costs there we go what
what what's the other thing that you
could possibly do what's if if we're not
doing this what are we going to
necessarily do as the alternative and so
what is the cost of getting rid of this
thing that was actually pretty good even
though it wasn't perfect and we end up
with this thing that arguably is worse
and so right yeah one way so actually go
ahead again so going back to your
definition of the cost management now so
that you're a little um explanation of
it that was actually one of the places
that I had on a a bit of an issue with
your your book on and I don't think it
was mostly your it wasn't your argument
it's definitely not your difference
between the you know percentage willing
to pay versus the absolute will
anticipate uh which is definitely like
if there was any other subtitle I would
call it that
um but
um when you you go from the utilitarian
argument of the using these words
specifically welfare happiness utility
good to money
I I was hoping for a more thorough
argument from you why you're going to
actually use those terminologies besides
just kind of going well the utilitarians
do this and we turn this into money via
the economists
um especially going on you you seem to
um transpose these words
um throughout the book and I I just was
going through this like just give me one
word that we're going to use
consistently here
um and especially because I I've read a
lot about like the philosophy of
happiness in the last couple years and
that is a wholly extra layer of things
that is totally outside of the
um the more smaller confines of
utilitarian ideas no that that that
that's a fair critique and I think I the
my uh laxness with uh terminology comes
probably more from the economic side of
how how these are referred to in
economics I think economists refer to
economists use the word utility they use
utility to mean Ace specific thing this
kind of underlying concept but they use
it interchangeably with welfare they use
it interchangeably with happiness and
these other things which I I agree is a
problem it's not the problem that I'm
focusing on necessarily in the book and
so I I'm probably a little sloppy with
my terminology there what I'm and to a
certain degree I'm being abstract and
being non-specific for a reason in that
I I think that there is a principle
concept that underpins this of whether
that's happiness or utility or pleasure
or preference or what have you whatever
of those Concepts you care the most
about I think that absolute willingness
to pay does a bad job of measuring it
and percentage willingness to pay does a
better job of measuring it and so I'm
I'm a little rough with those Concepts
because I think this argument can map
onto whatever your favorite kind of
concept is that fits in there I think I
have a small piece on it somewhere in
the book where I'm like these terms you
plug plug in your favorite argument here
um but I definitely agree it more
digging into detail on that particularly
because that connection between going
from whatever that Master concept that
we're adding up to to what we're really
measuring in terms of willingness to pay
is a key part of the book definitely is
is deserving of expansion
well now several times we've brought up
this distinction between
absolute willingness to pay and
percentage willingness to pay that plays
an absolutely Central role in the entire
argument of the book so can you walk us
through both you know first of all what
are these and how do they connect to
class benefit analysis and then how how
all how also do those connect up to how
we're valuing lives yeah because because
the key worry in the book is rich
people's lives or people in rich
countries are being valued more than
other people's lives unfairly right yeah
exactly great question so when we're
trying to add up all of these benefits
and and costs and cost benefit analysis
one thing that economists use is
something called willingness to pay
um and so you can think of this as what
are you willing to pay to get something
there are a lot of costs and benefits
that are easy to capture in money terms
where a government is spending so much
money to get a a carton of vaccines or a
box of donuts what whatever the
government's buying
um that's easy to capture but there are
other things that are harder to capture
so yeah how much does someone value the
Aesthetics of the beauty of having a
park outside of their house and to be
able to see that how much does someone
value reducing their chance of death by
one in a thousand
um these things are harder to capture
and so what economists use to capture
that is this willingness to pay Concepts
so how much would you be willing to pay
to have a park outside your apartment or
how much would you be willing to pay to
do that and then that's captured in a
benefit so if I would be a willing to
pay a thousand dollars a year for a park
outside my window that's captured as a
thousand dollar benefit if the
government decides to build a park next
to my house
um
and so one of the the the comparison
that's absolute willingness to pay the
concern that I raise in the book is that
absolute willingness to pay is
problematic because if I have a hundred
million dollars I can say you know what
I'd be willing to pay a million dollars
for a view outside my apartment yeah I
feel like I'd be willing to pay that and
someone that has only ten thousand
dollars to their name and says they'd be
willing to pay a thousand dollars for
the view outside their apartment as the
economists are framing it the person
who's paying a thousand dollars is a
thousand times less the benefit they're
really getting for the view and so we
should go build the park next to the
rich person's apartment
um and what I argue in the book is that
the better way to judge how much benefit
someone getting isn't this absolute
value but it's a percentage value of how
much you have so if I have ten thousand
dollars and I'd be willing to spend ten
percent of that a thousand dollars on
The View I value that more than someone
that has a hundred million dollars and
they'd only be willing to spend and a
million dollars they'd only be willing
to spend one percent of their wealth on
this and so the percentage there is
saying a better way to capture how much
someone actually values something and
how much benefit someone really gets
isn't the absolute amount that they have
because that's really just a feature of
how much money they have it's a the
percentage of their wealth
um and so the last question on value of
lives so economists one of the benefits
we can have is a reduction in mortality
risk so let's say we have a a law that
says everyone has to wear a seat belt
everyone across the population gets a
certain benefit from that they're having
a lower chance of death and so what
would you be willing to pay for that
benefit well most people want to live
and so would be willing to pay a certain
amount for the benefit of having a lower
chance of death
um yeah
and what happens is we find that when we
ask people lo and behold the wealthier
people are willing to pay more and the
poor people are willing to pay less
simply because they have less to pay and
when you calculate What's called the
value of a statistical life so the
average life saved by a policy you get
people who are in wealthy countries with
10 20 million dollar value statistical
life and people who are in uh poorer
countries with sixty thousand dollars uh
for a value of statistical life and
there's this huge difference but when
you calculate using percentage
willingness to pay amazingly all the
differences come out in the wash and
everyone has essentially almost exactly
the same value of statistical life
calculated in terms of the percentage
they'd be willing to pay for a small
reduction in their chance of death
um so sorry that was a couple questions
but hopefully that explains some of the
concepts in there no I think that I
think that's very helpful and there's
actually an appendix in the back of the
book that we're discussing are all lives
equal that has country by country what
the value of a statistical life is and
it's it I mean you can see them side by
side you know and they they very you
know I mean quite considerably
um so it's it's quite interesting to to
look at it and to see like where the
really high value places
uh I mean we're up there the the us but
there's there's uh like Australia has a
higher uh value of statistical life than
than the US in these obvious and
obviously Norway in the Scandinavian
countries do as well but
um that's I mean getting to actually see
those numbers I think is is quite
important
so you use the the vsl here the value of
the statistical life as one of your main
Independence for you know making a lot
of these arguments
um I guess this was maybe another small
critique because I was like I wanted
more
um arguments a lot along those lines to
actually get you to this kind of
well-being
um like because a lot of times it's like
okay how much to reduce risk or to you
know
um I guess take a more dangerous job
which are are very valid Arguments for
this but I wanted something a little bit
more comprehensive yeah I think what one
of the things that I'm trying to walk
here is
on this line of saying there are a lot
of different ways so I propose
percentage willingness to pay I think
there's a lot of mathematically there's
a lot of different ways that you can get
at some of these Concepts you could do a
statistical exercise to control for
welfare income in a different way when
you're doing your initial calculations
and so I'm trying there's a certain
level to which I'm trying not to put
forward this is absolutely the best way
to measure welfare or measure utility
it's to say rather that it is the
opportunity cost piece a bit this is a
better way across the board to measure
whatever that concept is than what we're
doing right now what we're doing right
now fails in terms of accuracy fails in
terms of Justice fails in terms of all
these pieces and so we have a better
option we could shift to and I don't
know if that's the right option I don't
know if it's the the perfect option I
don't know if if welfare or utility is
what we should be measuring or
preferences or happiness or what have
you but it seems like any of those
content is better captured by this
percentage thing than than the absolute
piece
um but but I definitely take the point
that digging into that argument is it it
it's a place perhaps for future writings
for sure
right
um so just I I love one you're talking
about just a little bit of the
um
in chapter six promoting things that are
beneficial and high utility that people
don't want and I wanted to go into that
and then later on I think like chapter
maybe 14 or something it's like and that
will be for another book I'm like oh
darn yeah I'll get there
um but we're about at the end of our
time is there anything you want to cap
off when uh not your final uh thought
but just like
something else you want to get out there
um no I mean just that the the book is
available uh it's available in paperback
it's now available in ebook form
um for anyone that's interested uh the
first chapter is available
um for free anyone can read it uh you
can check out the the website if you
want to learn learn more or or the
Channel with that but yeah I'm overall
thank you all so much for for having me
on the program uh this this has been a
lot of fun
um and thank you for the the great work
that you all do uh making public
philosophy out there making it more
engaging for people and and getting
people interested in philosophy
all right so uh once again here's our
our the book that we've been talking
about
um are all lives equal why cost benefit
analysis values Rich lives more and how
philosophy can fix it
so as our guest uh we'll let you take us
out on a final word uh a quote from your
book so what do you have for us
fantastic um so I'll pull something from
the first chapter in the first chapter
of one of the the things that I Center
is um this Memo from Lawrence Summers
that kind of outlines that uh these rich
lives are worth so much more than these
poor lives um so I'll I'll take a quote
uh specifically this one thing about
Summers that I think is really impactful
which is whether you think the memo was
written as a critique of the basic
economic principles that place lower
value on the lives of the poor or a
Manifesto supporting such a view doesn't
change the underlying economic logic
Summers is factually correct about what
economics implies even if he's morally
wrong
[Music]
foreign
[Music]